uh King Charles is set to host the first
state visit of Israel when he welcomes
South Africa's president Sarah ramaphosa
to the UK joined now by the former UK
High Commissioner to South Africa Lord
boating hello to my Lord thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
talk to us about your hopes and expect
it could hello uh talk to me about your
hopes and expectations for this visit
this is an important visit for Britain
South Africa is our major strategic
partner on the continent our biggest
trade partner Britain 2 is a major
investor in South Africa and the bonds
are are strong but there are a number of
key issues climate change the foremost
amongst them South Africa is very
heavily Reliant uh on coal it needs at
the same time to see jobs created so
delivering on the outcome of uh the
Egyptian uh cop will be hugely important
both for South Africa and of course uh
for for Britain and it's the first in
King Charles's Reign and that too is
significant because King Charles has a
long-standing relationship uh with uh
Africa built up over many years with him
making a significant contribution of
course to the preservation of Africa's
environment and Wildlife yeah and of
course his boy is very much involved in
Africa as well as was his uh former wife
um there are challenges though aren't
there I mean South Africa is I've been
there very recently they have um
significant uh problems when it comes
um to energy
um economic stagnation as well and and
the president himself is not without
controversy
I was present yesterday at South Africa
house and I think the theme for
president ramaphosa's visit will be no
one left behind uh that no uh one in
South Africa should not benefit uh from
uh development that the real challenge
is they face should be addressed and
they see trade and investment as a very
important part in that but South Africa
also demands and rightly uh respect it
won't be lectured about its stance its
neutral stance uh in international
Affairs and it looks uh to Britain and
the Commonwealth as equal and respectful
partners and the Commonwealth indeed
provides a good context for that sense
of mutual friendship responsibility but
but founded on a relationship of respect
for individual sovereignty
we very much remember Nelson Mandela
coming along to have a state visit I
think back in 1996 now I remember him
addressing uh both the houses of
Parliament at the time that visit went
down very well
um indeed can Cyril ramaphosa expect
anything along the same lines
there was something of course very
special about Nelson Mandela that no one
can hope to emulate uh but Cyril
ramaphosa is someone who's made a real
contribution on the world stage and
indeed to peace in Northern Ireland he
was a major interlocutor during that
very difficult time in helping negotiate
the peace Accord with Shin Fein he's
someone who is rightly respected and
someone who understands the needs of a
business who understands the importance
of building a dynamic economy so I've
got no doubt that this will be a
successful visit but it needs to be a
visit that is rooted in neutral respect
and understanding of the challenges that
the whole world faces around climate
change and the UK has an opportunity to
become for South Africa that a major
strategic partner in addressing the
issue of climate change and I think it
will do that I wonder my Lord if you
could um talk to our viewers this
morning
um about some of the controversy
surrounding the Cullen and uh diamonds
suggestions that our Queen should should
not wear that today that it would uh
cause offense to our South African
friends and neighbors uh what what is
the controversy surrounding it
I think there just needs to be an
understanding on all sides uh that
history is a complex matter we need in
the UK as a country to face up uh to the
reality of our Imperial past we need
also to recognize that there is for a
case uh for uh the return of many of the
artifacts held in our museums uh I don't
think the issue of a diamond in a crown
is going to Mar the relationship between
the UK and South Africa but I do feel
that it's very important that we
understand the complexities of history
that we face up to our responsibilities
and things were sort of things that were
wrong and that where we can we make
adequate and proper reparation but the
key you know and this is what I found
both are as a high commission and indeed
as a cabinet minister with
responsibility for the Africa commission
the key to good relationships going
forward is respect for the past of
course and its complexity but above all
respect now in terms of a relationship
of equals and I think South Africa and
Britain can do that South Africa is a
great country it's been through many
trials and tribulations Britain has
played its part in that but let's not
forget either that whatever British
governments in the past have done the
relationship between British people and
South African people has always been one
that has been based on that respect we
saw that in the anti-apartheid movement
when Britain and British people whatever
the government's position when British
people were the Forefront of the
struggle for freedom in South Africa and
we need to build on that relationship
between peoples I remember when I other
side commissioner rugby broke people
together uh sport can bring people
together and One Believes and hopes that
South Africa and Britain have a great
future together but one based on respect
for each other's sovereignty and
building okay uh future together yeah
who are you supporting in the world cup
to that end
I want a Ghana and England to be in the
finals and if we achieve that that would
be a great thing for both England and
garden after that well it's in the hands
of the Gods ah good answer it's good to
talk to you my Lord thank you
could say you guys have a k bye thank
you bye-bye